pas de vous tenir informé de la
situation et c'est avec plaisir que je
le fais aujourd'hui
premièrement sur la situation
épidémiologique
j'aimerais remercier tout d'abord les
travailleurs de la santé qui ont
sacrifié
leur temps des familles continuent de
sacrifier leur temps des fêtes pour
soigner les québécois dans des
circonstances on sait qu'ils sont pas
faciles mais je veux remercier aussi les
québécois qui auront sacrifié beaucoup
de réunions de famille et d'amis pour
éviter d'étendre la contagion comme une
hauteur qui est déjà très forte mais
malgré ça vous avez vu vous avez pu
contester la fulgurante aux décors dans
les deux dernières semaines et même je
vous dirais je pense qu'on s'en doute un
peu que ce n'est pas vraiment les le
vrai nom parce qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
corps dans la réalité à l'armée on ne
sait pas justement combien
mais ce qu'on essaie d'éviter par dessus
tout je serais pas surpris que je vous
dise à ces débordements du système de
santé comme à peu près partout en
occident on est pris dans un étau où les
hospitalisations augmente alors que de
plus en plus de soignants doivent
s'absenter
autrement dit on a de plus en plus de
malades et de moins en moins de monde
pour les soigner pour ce qui est des
hospitalisations je veux souligner qu'on
a encore beaucoup d'incertitudes sur les
caractéristiques du variant au micro on
continue d'échanger avec nos experts sur
le sujet mais il nous faut encore
quelques jours pour préciser les
projections que l'on vous fait
habituellement de nos experts en fait je
vais résumer il ya trois grandes
inconnues que nous avons sur un micron
en ce moment
premièrement on a pas encore de
certitude sur la sévérité de migrants
tout indique qu'il cause des symptômes
moins sévère que le delta mais jusqu'à
quel point est-ce que ça va permettre
par exemple de réduire les durées de
séjour on ne sait pas encore
deuxièmement on constate que la
situation en soins intensifs est
encourageante dans les anciennes vannes
on avait par exemple un code de soins
intensifs pour quatre spécialisations
l'eau au cours des derniers jours de la
dernière semaine on n'est plus à un code
de soins intensifs pour 10 codes
d'hospitalisation maintenant est ce que
cette tendance là va se maintenir et
même s'accentuer je vous dirais que ce
serait une très bonne nouvelle parce que
les soins intensifs c'est très près de
demandes en exigeant en terme de
personnel sur notre réseau est la
troisième grande inconnue c'est la cause
des hospitalisations et ça c'est
important de le voir avec les
statistiques que vous voyez tous les
jours depuis quelques semaines toutes
les personnes qui se présentent à
l'hôpital sont testés et comme la
transmission est très forte dans la
communauté
on a beaucoup de co positif et là il
faut qu'on arrive à départager les
hospitalisations qui sont dues à la
colline
de celles qui sont pour d'autres raisons
on doit le faire systématiquement pour
avoir un pote un portrait qui est juste
de la situation et pour savoir ce qu'il
nous attend dans les prochaines semaines
en fait on espère avoir des réponses à
ces trois points là et bien d'autres
dans les prochains jours mais on
pourrait avoir agir sans attendre
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on va faire
pour continuer de limiter donc pour
continuer de limiter les
hospitalisations
on met en place
immédiatement de nouvelles mesures
premièrement on va changer de paradigme
pour les travailleurs de la santé je
vais l'expliquer en détail et
deuxièmement on va ajouter de nouveaux
groupes pour la troisième dose
maintenant c'est mon deuxième point
quelles sont les nouvelles mesures
convenons cpo le personnel la santé
j'ai rencontré avec mes collègues les
syndicaux d'un dans les derniers jours
et encore une fois ce matin avec non
seulement les syndicats du réseau de la
santé mais aussi les professionnels
comme les associations de médecins de
pharmaciens en fait on a mis tout le
monde ensemble pour faire le point
mettre en place ces nouvelles mesures en
fait je vous résume vrai qu'on a un
enjeu de société et c'est la même chose
un peu partout dans le monde la
contagion par micron elle est tellement
exponentielle qu'on doit retirer
énormément de personnel quand j'ai
expliqué et ça ça nous pose un risque
sur la capacité du réseau à soigner les
québécois cela nous impose d'effectuer
un changement de paradigme qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que dans les
vagues précédent qu'est ce qu'on faisait
on identifier et on retirait le plus
vite possible
les employés qui étaient un risque mais
avec le niveau actuel de vaccination
puis on est chanceux on à 98% notre
personnel qui est vaccinée dans le
réseau de la santé on peut faire
autrement lorsqu'on a le choix
il a en concertation avec la santé
publique avec les directions clinique du
ministère de l'inesss pq on a pris la
décision que sous certaines conditions
le personnel qui est positif pourra
continuer de travailler selon une
priorité une liste de priorités mais
aussi une gestion des risques et je
rappelle que ce n'est pour uniquement
pour les travailleurs de la santé oms
travaille aussi pour que cette mesure
s'applique à tous les travailleurs
essentiels- pris uniquement ceux de la
santé si on veut que nos sociétés
continuent de fonctionner de façon
sécuritaire et les détails de sa
viendront dans les prochains jours en
fait le résume si on avait le personnel
qu'il faut on n'aurait pas besoin de
poser ce geste mais l'or en ce moment
on doit prendre des mesures très
concrètes et très pratique c'est une
gestion de risque une question de
balance des inconvénients
j'avais dit que je vous tiendra informés
il ya quelques jours on parlait de 4000
travailleurs qui étaient absents hier
c'était environ 6000 et je pense que
dans les prochains jours ces dix mille
travailleurs qui seront absents pour la
pour raison de l'aco vide alors dans les
circonstances vous comprendrez qu'on est
mieux faire travailler un employé qu'on
aurait retiré à 20 en autant qu'on le
fasse sous certaines conditions pour
éviter des bris de service
vous garantis qu'avec du copper corp qui
va être fait en fonction de chacune des
sept des situations qui sont propres à
chaque région on le voit partout dans le
monde tous les réseaux trouve ou santé
sont confrontés aux mêmes décisions
rappel on prend cette décision parce
qu'on aime mieux faire ça que d'aller au
dernier niveau de délestage qui implique
de faire seulement les soins critiques
alors si on se met à faire plus de
délestage on risque d'avoir des domaines
du dommage pardon permanent pour les
usagers
notre priorité ça restera toujours la
même c'est de soigner les québécois qui
en ont besoin
je vais essayer de vous donner des
bonnes nouvelles aujourd'hui
troisièmement la vaccination de la
troisième dose
on a déjà maintenant avec la bonne
semaine qu'on ne juge sont un petit peu
avant noël on a maintenant un peu plus
qu'un million de 3e de route qui ont été
données et à compter de demain demain on
va élargir de nouveaux groupes
premièrement sur les clientèles
prioritaires
les groupes pour prendre rendez vous
c'est sur les travailleurs de la santé
du privé et autres travailleurs de la
santé comme pour les soins palliatifs
les entreprises qui sont d'économie
sociale et des dames domicile le
personnel qui est en milieu scolaire les
organismes communautaires de la ces et
des services sociaux que j'en profite
pour pour saluer insécurité pas de lieux
publics les inspecteurs du mapaq et le
personnel des abattoirs pour la chaîne
alimentaire c'est très important et je
rappelle que la vaccination est déjà
ouverte pour les éducatrices
les premiers répondants et toute une
série de travailleurs je vous demande de
vous informer pour le détail
pour la population générale et c'est ce
que je crois que la bonne nouvelle
daniel pourra vous donner des détails
tout à l'heure mais par la suite ce sera
au tour de la population générale les 18
à 59 ans dès le 4 janvier c'est dans les
prochains jours on va ouvrir les rendez
vous par groupes de cinq ans comme nous
l'avons fait avant ce qui nous amène
jusqu'au 21 janvier et on va publier
comme nous faisons habituellement le
calendrier de vaccination pour ces
groupes dangereux
et je veux rappeler aussi pour les
groupes qui sont en cours des fois les
gens l'oublient mais je veux rappeler
que pour les 60 ans et plus les
personnes avec des maladies chroniques
les travailleurs de la santé et les
doubles vacciner d'astrazeneca peuvent
déjà prendre un rendez vous pour leur
troisième dose on va continuer
d'accélérer la troisième dose parce
qu'on veut en fait vacciner de deux à
trois millions de personnes par mois ce
qui nous amènerait en mars pour avoir
vacciné l'entièreté de la population
alors mais je le rappelle inquiétez vous
pas si vous voulez prendre votre
rendez-vous et qu'il ait plusieurs
semaines plus tard l'idée pour nous
c'est de prévoir les opérations et on va
rajouter des rendez-vous disponibles au
fur et à mesure qu'on aura la capacité
pour le faire
maintenant
jamais j'aimerais m'adresser encore une
fois aux non vaccinés et à leurs proches
vous devez savoir
que c'est beaucoup les non vaccinés qui
se retrouvent aux soins intensifs et qui
luttent pour leur vie présentement et
même un survivant il ya souvent des
séquelles qui peuvent être graves et
durée pour le restant de vos jours
avec les statistiques des derniers jours
et avec la venue d'auch microns je veux
être très clair très très clairs au
cours des prochains mois si la tendance
se maintient des derniers jours et je
parle au nom vaccinés ou bien vous allez
vous faire vacciner ou bien vous allez
faire la maladie il faire la maladie
quand vous êtes non vaccinés c'est de
mettre une pression inutile sur notre
réseau de santé
je le rappelle il n'est jamais trop tard
pour se faire vacciner
allez-y vous pouvez aussi faire partie
de la solution
alors en conclusion je voulais je
voudrais que chacun d'entre nous pensent
aux travailleurs de la santé qui sont au
front
aux infirmières nos médecins nos
préposés nous technicienne laboratoire
nos inhalothérapeutes les pharmacies et
j'en oublie
je m'en excuse par respect pour eux je
vous implore de prendre les mesures pour
limiter la contagion
j'aimerais rappeler aux québécois que la
meilleure façon de ne pas attraper la
coved et de ne pas la transmettre et
d'éviter des rassemblements et de
réduire le contact au minimum chacun a
sa responsabilité
de limiter les contacts surtout pour les
personnes de 60 ans et plus qui n'ont
pas encore leur 3 12 pour ce qui est
encore plus dangereux pour
veux vous assurer
qu'on va continuer de suivre la
situation de près et on vous reviendra
avec des mesures supplémentaires si on a
besoin de le faire au fur et à mesure
que les experts auront des nouvelles
informations sur un micro d'ici là bon
courage tout le monde et je vous
remercie
sefyu
je continue les motorisations
ting tings first
par défaut car workers and they can't we
and you groupes fondateurs doses
ouimette de new new new in the last days
and again this morning tout protein
crise majeure for health workers au
micro quant aux jeunes ils sont
exponentielles dare you see no more of
personnel have to be good run and poor's
risque today network est passé du tout
risque au bac 2 et de force aux to make
up and down shift in previous while we
wanted and find and we move at risk and
police as quickly espace ball wii de 40
les vaccinations we have to do and the
ways we have no choice in consulting it
pas besoin de décodeur actions
indiennes spq oui mais deux de ses
jeunes date under se retourne
conditions' du staff urbi et bolt
continue working à kolding touristes
priority and risk management est un fake
or des chercheurs
notent geste elle car workers and
provide une formation de coming days
non on doit perdre aux faux tout le
monde l'expert de new groupe se
creuse à
sa chasse palliative care and soul
chaude économie enterprises staff comme
une utilité sociale sont organisés jeune
public security mapaq inspecteurs en
soit cela raul staff savent sans compter
et will be done
general population et tindouf et teen
idol from giannoli fort
deux communes we continue to ma nature
de situations closely elle will be back
to you et à des jeunes majeurs et fnideq
as des expertes avenue à une formation
au micro merci thank you je vais prendre
des questions à monsieur dubé nous
allons maintenant et débuté la période
de questions nous commencerons avec les
questions en français dans la salle et
nous poursuivrons avec les questions
apprise en virtuel et nous finirons avec
les questions en anglais dans la salle
et par la suite en virtuel merci de
respecter une questions et une
suggestion par journalisme notre micro 2
donc bryn arriver de nouveau d'abord ça
te comprendre la mesure pour le
personnel les travers de la santé où
nous dit qu'ils sont complètement épuisé
à bout supplie manque de personnel de
les faire travailler avec l'aco vide
presque pas de mettre les mettre encore
plus à terre
écoutez si on avait le choix entre pas
dans toute gestion du risque d'un réseau
comme celui de la santé il faut vous
trouvez l'équilibré
lorsqu'on a bien expliqué plus votre
question est très à propos qu'on l'a
discuté avec les représentants syndicaux
dans les derniers jours on leur dit on
de deux joueurs le personnel il existe
pas en ce moment les polos et on a deux
joueurs ou bien on force ceux qui sont
là à rester plus longtemps si ce que
permettent les fameuses à l'été 007
qu'on essaye d'utiliser au minimum
où on demande aux gens de rester plus
longtemps alors on essaye de trouver une
meilleur équilibre mais comme je les ai
répétés ou aux représentants syndicaux
dans les derniers jours on a un enjeu
qu'on sait depuis longtemps ça nous
prend du personnel additionnel le les
gens le comprennent mieux que la
première chose à faire c'est d'aller
chercher du personnel mais en ce moment
dans une situation tellement urgente et
critique à court terme qu'on essaye de
prendre le moindre des deux mots c'est
ça qu'on propose est en dessous question
le cdc aux états unis dit bouclier
l'isolément peut passer de 10 jours à
cinq jours pour les personnes
asymptomatiques est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous regardez présentent eux
fait tout à fait on commence la première
étape parce que c'est quand même des
discussions je pourrais passer la parole
à dr 2 mais effectivement va peut-être
falloir aller plus loin puis je pense
qu'on on comprend très bien ce que le
cdc aux états unis
je
peux voir le problème est partout dans
le monde actuellement c'est un pacs est
aux transmissions va rendre des travers
de la santé malade certains
symptomatique certes un peu
symptomatiques certains qui peuvent
encore travailler mais on y voit avec
une gestion du risque était discuté
notamment avec toutes les directions
clinique du ministère pour vérifier t-il
d'autres alternatives avant de scander
ça mais force est de constater que si
celui-ci en peu de temps le 23 et mis
des choses et lendemain ajoute la
question de cinq jours c'est parce que
la problématique est réelle elle n'est
pas seulement au québec
les 3 wii et les honneurs de radio
canada j'aimerais avoir quelques
précisions au niveau des
hospitalisations parce que d'après les
données
d'après les données du ministère de la
santé le nombre de coeurs a porté en
date du 26 décembre n'est pas le même
que l'ombre de corps a porté par lee 1
sp cure on parle de 146 pour le
ministère
239 pour lui et respectueux alors
j'aimerais savoir précisément combien de
nouvelles missions hospitalières ont été
rapportés et en combien une jour laisse
que celles pour le 26 et le 27 mai en
fait le 25 et 26 décembre le 239
expliquez moi ça on va regarder ça très
simple le bon chiffre qu'on a publié ce
matin ses bons chiffres 546
hospitalisation de toutes sortes
d'ajustement que les aspects qui fait
mais je pense que depuis le début qu'on
publie nos chances et les banques alors
aujourd'hui les hospitalisations ses 146
si une chose ya peut-être moins
d'hospitalisations c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure c'est ça que je
veux que les gens comprennent c'est que
ça on essaye de trouver les bonnes
nouvelles où il y en a et je le répète
en ce moment lorsque quelqu'un arrive à
l'hôpital je veux donner cet exemple une
dame qui vient pour accoucher elle peut
venir pour accoucher sans même savoir
que les lacunes en ce moment elle entre
dans les statistiques covin parce que vu
que les tester en a trop on dit que
l'écho vide alors à ce moment c'est ce
qu'on a demandé dîner spécule c'est pas
d'avoir plus de corps mais on en a
probablement moins on estime en ce
moment là basé sur les travaux parce que
avec micron ça va tellement vite donc je
profite de votre question pour dire si
une chose en soi mais c'est peut-être
qu'il ya un petit peu moins et c'est ça
qui nous a poussés avec nos experts et
rieur d'attendre un petit peu avec de
prendre quelques jours de plus pour
essayer de bien connaître ce chiffre là
mais ils pourraient aussi important de
25 à 30 pour ça alors c'est pour ça
qu'avant de prendre d'autre décision
très grave au cours des prochains jours
qu'on voulait avoir ces clarifications
en parlant justement de clarification on
sait qu'il ya des directions de santé
publique notamment à québec et à
montréal qui recommande aux gens
symptomatique de d'effectuer des tests
rapides à la maison et de ne pas se
présenter dans une clinique de dépistage
alors on a l'impression qu'on ne sait
plus exactement communiqué de claude
cauvy 19 au québec comment allez vous
faire pour comptabiliser ces camps peu
transparents disparu du réseau de la
santé puis avoir un portrait réel de la
situation au québec compte tenu des
tests rapides pythie directive quand
j'ai dit tout à l'heure puis j'apprécie
votre question parce que c'est un peu un
contexte qui change tellement vite on
n'aurait jamais pensé il ya quelques
semaines qu'on aurait autant de corps
par jour avec en gros en ce moment notre
priorité c'est de vacciner les gens ça
c'est notre priorité puis on a décidé de
faire moins de traçage pour toutes ces
bonnes raisons et pour répondre à votre
question est ce qu'on pourra un jour
dans les prochains jours décidé qu'on a
c'est d'accumuler une information suc
sont testés humain je vous dirai
peut-être mais en ce moment c'est pas
notre priorité une priorité c'est de
rendre dit etait-ce rapide disponible le
plus rapidement possible ce qu'on a fait
en pharmacie j'espère qu'on en aura
d'autres du fédéral dans les prochains
jours puis si on en a pas d'eau du
fédéral mon collègue que vous voyez ici
avec moi le super et travaille très fort
pour en obtenir dos à ce moment notre
priorité c'est que les gens se fassent
dépister qu'on essayera d'avoir des
statistiques de pouvoir communiquer avec
ces gens de trouver une façon de
communiquer avec ceux qui n'ont pas été
un centre de dépistage pour essayer
d'avoir les meilleures statistiques
possible mais en ce moment on est en
train d'essayer de regarder comment on
peut le faire merci
anne marie provost le devoir concernant
la cette nouvelle mesure de permettre
aux employés positive de continuer à
travailler il n'y a pas un risque de
contaminer d'autres travailleurs sur les
lieux de travail qui ont pas testé
positif un risque de contaminer des
patients qui sont vulnérables des gens
vulnérables parce que c'est des milieux
de travail qui peuvent être assez fluide
donc il n'y a pas ce risque qui existe
mais j'expliquais tout à l'heure adam
que c'était une question de gestion du
risque si on avait enlevé loin on ferait
pas soyons très clairs ne fait pas ça
pas de gaieté de coeur par contre les
conditions dans lesquelles on le fait
puis j'aimerais peut-être demander
docteur arruda compléter ma réponse mais
je vais vous dire deux choses
des gens qui travaillent en ce moment
dans le réseau de la santé c'est un peu
comme tous les coques vous connaissez
pas ce qu'on attendait tous les gens qui
particulièrement ceux qui sont
asymptomatiques en ce moment il y en a
beaucoup et ce qu'on dit c'est que il ya
dans le réseau de santé maintenant des
mesures de protection contrôle des
infections qui était pas en place même à
la première vague on sait que ceux ci la
plus grande différence la deuxième
différence et je lui dis nos
travailleurs de la santé sont destinés à
98% de 2
98% alors à ce moment là le risque qu'on
prend c'est un risque et contrôlée on
sait que ces gens là sont vaccinés et on
sait que ces jeunes s'ils sont positifs
seraient beaucoup moins contagieux puis
en plus qui ont les bonnes mesures de
masques il ya eu des demandes qui nous
ont été faits pour deux des mesures de
protection de contrôles additionnels des
épis additionnel on va tous respecter
les recommandations de la snes donc on
le fait pas par gaieté de coeur mais on
le fait dans un environnement contrôlé
si vous me permettez un must illuminé
jouer avec un élément vous comprendre
qu'actuellement avec le thé réellement
au niveau transmission aussi dans la
communauté que certains travers de santé
peuvent l'attraper
et quand on les retourne en milieu de
soins on les retourne dans les ongles ou
on le regarde chacune des situations
depuis cette petite uation on le
retourne dans les endroits où plupart
des gens infectés et le travers le
centre effecté on s'assure qu'ils
portent les pays comme le dit le
ministre puis aussi on s'assure qu'ils
ne signent pas avec d'autres employés
parce que c'est elle est souvent la
contamination se faisait non pas l'heure
du milieu de soins fait juste dire que
dans le fond oui effectivement dans un
monde idéal on voit des personnes
malades dans un milieu en même temps je
vais juste ajouté le milieu des gens ont
besoin de soins je pourrais vous
comprenez moi si j'étais aux soins
intensifs que j'ai besoin d'un
cardiologue
comme tel je préfère un cardiologue qui
vont être infectées à la cuvée 2009 peu
symptomatiques après cet intérieur des
plus contagieux a plaidé me jeu il va
s'occuper de mon coeur parce que maurice
de mourir du carré plus important c'est
que c'est là qu'on est en termes de
gestion du risque je vous c'est
important que vous comprenez que c'est
que d'autres maladies que la coved 19 et
puis il faut s'occuper de nos patients
qui ont besoin de soins
sinon par rapport à troisième dose on
sait qu à ce moment ci a peut-être un
peu plus de confusion entre que du côté
des québécois sur qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire et tout ça parce que les choses
des boules rapidement est ce que vous
sentez que ça va être plus difficile de
mobiliser les québécois cette fois ci
que lorsqu'on éjecter les deux premières
doses mais je vais je vais répondre la
première partie puis j'ai demandé à mon
collègue ce pari de compléter écouter
pour moi non s'il ya des gens qui
avaient encore un doute que la troisième
dose est importante le jeu parce que
voir le nombre de douze mille 3000 puis
peut-être demain 15000 coll
et je pense que la troisième douze
convois sont une évidence il ya des pays
en ce moment qu'ils arrachent les
vaccins pour être capable de faire une
première dose nous on est chanceux
d'avoir accès au troisième tour alors
sur ce point là je pense que
malheureusement la situation avec micron
qui fait passer de pour ceux qui ont une
deuxième dose jusque est jusqu'à
maintenant que je rappelle la
statistique quand on avait deux doses
dans un monde qui aussi loin quand on
avait le delta on avait une protection
de 75 81 85 pour ça cette protection
l'homme malheureusement bien baissé à 30
% avec aux migrants alors oui ça a été
une bonne chose d'avoir les deux doses
mais pour ceux qui ont déjà rendu à la
troisième passer à la troisième parce
que vous allez rattraper le niveau de
protection que vous aviez avait à peu
près avec le delta donc pour moi c'est
même pour nous c'est même pas une
question c'est une évidence mais tous
nos experts le disent maintenant ce que
je voudrais que daniel woods il sait
comment on est capable de vacciner et ça
c'est notre chance qu'on a parce qu'on
veut le prouver alors peut-être que
daniel pourrait vous donner quelques
statistiques de ce qu'on peut faire oui
mais bonjour à tous nous avons misé au
lendemain d'un troisième dose
seulement hier plus de 270 vaccin là
excusez moi un rendez vous pour une dose
de vaccin et
la population et l'ont demandé
justement on
accueille
aujourd'hui et la population est jeune
et je pense dépasser la contradiction au
mois de juin
[Musique]
d'accès
florence maret martel de la presse on
sait que le manque de personnel touche
aussi les laboratoires de dépistage et
je me demandais comment vous allez vous
assurer que la capacité dépistage soit
maintenue
écoutez c'est pour ça tout à l'heure que
je les ai remerciés un trouve notre
personnel des laboratoires parce que moi
je comprend pas comment on a réussi à
faire jusqu'à plus de 50
analyse au cours des derniers jours ce
qui est inscrite à un record parmi
les maximum qu'on croyait avoir atteint
alors jusqu'à maintenant sa peau était
un enjeu je pense que c'est
je le répète les gens qui vont se faire
vacciner au centre de dépistage devrait
des gens qui ont des décors qui sont
positifs on pense qu'avec ce qu'on a mis
en place avec le et s rapide on peut
diminuer l'achalandage puis quand même
permettent lizonne mans déjà qu'ils ont
qui ont des symptômes et je vous dis je
remercie tout le monde que dans ces
moments-là très difficile tout notre
personnel fait un effort incroyable
c'est pour ça que je le répète fous les
appuis vous trouver une façon d appui
plus de minimiser nos contacts à propos
de la vaccination est selon les données
ou la vaccination chez les cinq ans aux
en demeure fiable à montréal et que
comptez vous faire pour encourager
davantage la vaccination
mais moi je vous trouve dur quand vous
dites que c'est faible parce que puis je
vois sourire daniel parce que parce que
beaucoup de on est rendu je ne le sais
pas les derniers 50 buts pour sa
descente jusqu'à maintenant alors que
l'école est terminée mais peut-être
laissé je me suis pareil engouement sur
youtube il s'était 58% devait de l'engin
de cinq ans vise à
occulter verte le kid et demi c'est long
en bien d'autres c'est le cv le système
scolaire ou affectés au niveau du camp
politique dont nous n'irons chercher le
1er
mai on soit
il pour répondre à votre question on va
rester ou va continuer de bénéficier des
bienfaits avec son gros jeunes et non
nous ne donnerons
quelques
passes très merci daniel puis
j'inviterai les parents qui vont
chercher la troisième dose d'en profiter
pour amener leurs enfants parce que ya
peut-être moins de choses à faire durant
le temps des fêtes en ce moment alors
aura peut-être que ce sera une belle
activité de l'est au centre de
vaccination
j'essayais d'avoir un peu d'humour
aujourd'hui
oui bonjour jean françois tremblay à tva
je vais revenir sur les tests rapides le
ministre fédérale de la santé disait
qu'en date du 23 décembre le québec en
avait reçu 9.4 millions et que au 31
décembre la province en or à 11.2 c'est
même un peu plus que ce que vous aviez
demandé cependant dans les pharmacies
des citoyens les cherche ces tests là
ils sont où les tests ce qu'on volé ce
que les gens vont pouvoir avoir leur
petite boîte de synthèse rapidement
dès le début et puis 6 millions ou rodez
et haut niveau nos économies et de 90,5
millions ou au niveau des pharmacies et
qui ont effectivement on est preneur les
mécontents bois
et j'espère un
gérant du pouvoir la faire que vos
prochaines livraisons au nom en anglais
- devenir en place un système de gestion
communautaire qui vit alors 2000
ce qu'on va recevoir
dans les livres ou les québécois avec
l'apport de 12 mois ou d'un certain
échéance entre le moi de main pour le
moins de juin les librairies mais un des
bons aspects dès lors impossible et 2 2
millions d'un ancien de la
maison en
jouant à data systems
le québécois ça va aller
allez-y pour votre situation ensuite on
va passer aux journalistes en france est
en ligne est-ce que vous avez évalué
monsieur dubé en permettant le retour
des travailleurs positif en faisant la
gestion du risque sur l'exemple
d'aujourd'hui où vous parlez de 8000
combien pourrait revenir quelle attitude
ça vous donne avant d'être confronté à
une bride service ou un délestage actuel
n'est et calcul qu'on fait tous les
jours comme je vous disais en ce moment
on est tout près de 8000 puis je pense
que si la tendance continue on va se
rapprocher du 10000 personnes qui vont
être simple pour la commune alors c'est
sûr que la situation que je le répète
que c'est pas du mur un mur qu'on va
faire on va s'ajuster
par les régions c'est ce qu'on a demandé
à nos ânes ou pdg pire aux responsables
de bien trouver la façon de minimiser
l'impact mais c'est sûr que si c'est
comme parker région par région hôpital
par hôpital ch et celle des toutous y
parle en ce moment pour être sûr qu'on
minimise l'impact d'une telle mesure
mais encore une fois on a vécu dans la
première vague des bris de service qui
ont occasionné à des gens de pas avoir
plus particulièrement en ces achats se
dit ne pas avoir de service on ne veut
pas revivre ça c'est pour ça que malgré
le choix difficiles qu'on fait on pense
que c'est le meilleur choix
nous allons maintenant poursuivre avec
la période de questions avec les
journalistes en virtuel donc vous invite
à lever la main sur la plateforme mme
clara loiseau
oui bonjour est-ce que vous m'entendez
oui oui bonjour alors mais moi j'ai pu
constater qu' il est plus en plus
difficile de trouver les rendez vous
pour se faire dépister on a certains
endroits où il faut attendre jusqu'au
jusqu'au 5 janvier à moins de changer de
religion à montréal il ya plusieurs
centres qui n'ont carrément plus de
disponibilité alors qu'est ce que vous
comptez faire pour régler cette
situation la
manière de le tuer
oui je peux je peux m'avancer le 60 m
haies effectivement nos centres de
dépistage sont occupés ont des capacités
le maximum de nos capacités fixe nouveau
laboratoire
lui par jour et là ça nous amène permet
responsable nationale
1 pour les centres de dépistage de le
dire dans des scènes de fête au bem
il s'isole et leur
constance là et on est
autour se responsabiliser le dire les
rognons de veau tant délictuelles
contenu
avoir maximisé
parti remercie pour la deuxième question
justement les tests de dépistage rapide
ou évidemment c'est une
stabilité des coûts alors que la vague
est ce que vous pensez créé platement
pour que les québécois puissent inscrire
il ya des aspirations et
on n'a pas assez à son nom non on a
beaucoup de jacky sont occupés à autre
chose en ce moment je vais le dire comme
cela parce que on est vraiment en guerre
pour vacciner le plus grand nombre de
personnes de toutes les façons mais si
ça s'avère moi j'ai des rencontres
encore avec basse ou minet cet après
midi pour discuter de la praticabilité
de 200 avec
avec monsieur parent et puis si on pense
que c'est la bonne chose à faire pour
avoir de meilleures statistiques on le
fera mais toutes sortes d'enjeux
opérationnel parce que là ce moment leur
fille jade est ce qu'on va voir
l'information qui qui est un propos
faire le match avec les gens qui ont
déjà une deuxième dose de toutes sortes
de considérations mais je vous
répondrais
facilement d un couillon le regarde mais
il ya peut-être d'autres priorités en ce
moment avec tout ce qu'on vient discuter
aujourd'hui je suis mené si vous me
permettez je voudrais aussi ajouter le
fait que toutes les juridictions qui ont
introduit les tests je voudrais rapides
ont eu une perte de formation c'est un
phénomène partout à travers le monde est
ce qu'il faut comprendre aussi on vous
l'avait dit que notre indicateur
principal les aspects clés soins
intensifs
c'est agréable d'avoir le bon chiffre de
façon le jeu mais le chiffre n'est
jamais le vrai nom parce que quand on
n'a pas beaucoup de capacités de
dépistage on a dit puisqu'une seule
partie quand on a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup on va avoir des plus gros
chiffre lui aussi qu'on peut même pas
comparer les chiffres d'un pays à
l'autre à cause notamment par rapport
aux cas notamment à cause de ces
variations le dépistage donc je veux pas
dire qu'il faut posséder faire un effort
pour avoir le meilleur portrait mais moi
nettement ce qui importe actuellement la
wii le nombre de corps parce que ça vous
permet de dire que ça se transmet
beaucoup plus je pense que deux jours à
douze mille cas par jour je suis plus un
message à dire aux québécois si vous
voulez pas l'attraper parce qu'il est
excessivement violent diminuer vos
contacts si vous n'avez pas besoin de
sortir ne sortait pas fait pas des
rassemblements un juge pas nécessaire
que ce soit 12000 ou 20000 c'est le même
message nous ce qui est très important
par contre voir est passé expliquent les
soins intensifs je veux pas minimiser
chiffres mais juste que vous compreniez
pour une prise de décision et je préfère
les gens soient vaccinés dès 60 ans et
plus et de la population à travers la
santé achats de la vaccination que
d'aussi d'accumuler des statistiques
commentaire là quand même mais oubliez
pas on regarde les auspices
frédéric lacroix couture la presse
canadienne
oui bonjour monsieur vous avez parlez
plutôt de la possibilité d'ajouter des
mesures supplémentaires ah c'est ça
quelles pourraient être ces mesures
supplémentaires est ce que le couvre-feu
est aujourd'hui dans les plans une
possibilité est à ce moment ci
écoutez c'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on
fait tous les jours c'est de considérer
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de plus je
rappelle que les québécois dans un
contexte mondial sont ceux qui ont le
plus de mesures en ce moment et
on a regardé en effet qu'une veille
internationale depuis des semaines de ce
qui se passe dans l'est des pays
européens incluant le incluant le
couvre-feu ou différentes versions du
couvre-feu mais moi j'aimerais un prof
profiter de votre question pour vous
donner une statistique qui a énormément
beaucoup d'impact sur nous puis sur nos
experts en soi mais si vous prenez juste
il ya quelques semaines la proportion
des vaccinés versus les non vaccinés qui
rentrait à l'hôpital était d'à peu près
1 pour 3 c'est à dire qu'ils avaient
beaucoup des vaccinés mais la grande
majorité étant donné qu'on avait 6
millions de québécois qui était double
attaque siné qui malheureusement
pourraient contracter la maladie je vous
donnerai le lin verse le changement qui
est arrivé avec au micro dans les
derniers jours prenez juste la journée
d'hier docteur arruda vient dire qu'on a
eu douze mille coy 12000 code déclaré
sur 12000 qu'a déclaré hier et on a
environ 8000 qui est un non vaccinés ça
ça veut dire que c'est déjà qu'ils
rendent à l'hôpital c'est des gens qui
vont aller aux soins intensifs alors
pour moi sur quelque chose à se rappeler
qui est en train d'arriver
et c'est pour ça que je les dis tantôt
dans mon allocution
si la tendance se maintient
tout les vaccine tous les non vaccinés
au cours des prochains mois bon soit se
faire vacciner ce qui serait la bonne
chose à faire où vont contracter la
maladie alors je le rappelle les
chiffres sont têtus
malheureusement c'est ce qui est en
train d'arriver ici là quand vous étiez
d'autrefois qui avait plaidé souvent
qu'ils avaient à peu près 600 mille
personnes qui étaient non vaccinés au
rythme d'aujourd'hui et des derniers
jours à moins 3 mois tous les non
vaccinés m'en avoir contracté la maladie
c'est à eux de décider de quel côté ils
veulent se trouvait
et certains suggèrent de repousser le
retour en classe c'est pour les écoles
primaires et secondaires pour l
enseignement supérieur est ce que c'est
une option il mesure que vous envisagez
le seigneur
tout et tout est sur la table mais si on
a toujours gardé la question des écoles
ouverte le plus longtemps passé pour une
foule de raisons pas c'est un choix de
société qu'on a fait mais c'est sûr
qu'on va regarder comment évoluent les
choses oublie pour le moment on a parlé
du 10 janvier puis j'aimerais qu'on
reste avec ce cette date l'on attaque
pour le moment
pascal de journal métro
bonjour messieurs
c'est selon les derniers chiffres donc
de données de santé québec il y
actuellement 580 cette hospitalisation
est en soins intensifs
115 alors on se rapproche petit à petit
donc des capacités réelles qui sont
mentionnés sur simply québec qui disent
de 825 personnes hospitalisées or swim
intensive et de 110 112 intensif veux
qu'on se rapproche petit à petit s'il ya
quand même une façon de rassurer la
population sur la capacité hospitalière
du québec monsieur occupé mais vous avez
vu
merci que la question vous avez vu il ya
deux semaines qu'on a clos jeudi de deux
semaines c'était mon port au jour exact
mais on augmenter la capacité
d'hospitalisation d'hélico vide en
faisant du délestage on est passé en
gros lot du niveau 2 de délestage au
niveau 3 c'est ce qui nous a permis de
passer d'à peu près 600 lits à 810 pour
les hospitalisations
mais je le répète c'est là qu'on ne veut
pas aller en ce moment d'aller au niveau
4 qui nous permettrait de ne faire que
des soins intensifs alors c'est pour ça
qu'on demande étant donné le nombre de
personnels qui est absent ou qui sera
absent qu'on a annoncé des mesures
d'aujourd'hui donc ça c'est pour ce
qu'on vous demande au personnel ce qu'on
demande aux québécois puis encore une
fois je le répète c'est d'être capable
de limiter les contacts les québécois
l'ont très bien fait puis même durant
les fêtes on a vu la baisse du niveau
des contacts avec les nouvelles mesures
qu'on me fait je le répète si un groupe
qui peut nous a aidés à se masser les
non-vaccinés
jusqu'au mans je vais vous continuez sur
ce sujet les non vaccinés
je sais que monsieur horacio arruda
n'est pas que faire des comparaisons
avec d'autres zones du monde mais par
exemple l'autriche a mis en place
l'obligation vaccinale l'allemagne est
en train de l'envisager et je voulais
simplement savoir au québec on va
scanner ce débat est ce que c'est un
visage et c'est sur la table ou à côté
de la table
écoutez il faut comprendre que tout est
est sur la table actuellement ce jour
que on a toujours pensé que c'est
toujours mieux de convaincre les jeunes
mais tout dépendamment de la menace est
ce que ça peut représenter il pourrait y
avoir des décisions qui sont prises aux
autres j'ai culturellement selon les
pays c'est différent au début certains
pays voudraient plus dictatoriaux qui
l'ont qui pourrait leur imposer à
l'ensemble de la société
on a vu qu'on a essayé de le faire
notamment aussi d'écouter d'être à
l'heure de la santé ça pas toujours été
évident depuis on a quand même augmenté
de façon significative la couverture
vaccinale je pense que c'est une chose à
regarder ce n'est pas une note première
mesure bien en bien entendu différents
enjeux associations mais je ne ferme pas
la porte à rien vous avez un kobe 19 n'y
en a pas il faut apprendre c'est qu'il
faut pour penser jeudi dès le premier
point de presse ne verra jamais pensé
que c'était autant ce qu'est ce qu'on
dit aujourd'hui peut être différent
demain et je peux vous dire que l'eau
micron san état de ce qui nous amène à
nous réagit très rapidement
nous sommes maintenant rendus à la
période de questions pour les
journalistes en anglais donc pour ceux
présents dans la salle
micro 1 c'est tabou
le king
avec un
collègue danielle de niese le king a eu
droit ce week end par les feuilles côté
vous voulez un daniel muquet nature
d'atenco 28 rendre des comptes comme
outsider l'écouté
just wanna make that we have the right
there is especially
le kenya attarde à dammaj iphone tu as
good as castet you need is money
is that our attraction 800 programmes
détruit à 90 membres
bacanov
tout
de même
ce passionné de long terme nageuse une
audi victime d'un hold up to help him
down there has been extend tout
l'hexagone
il est tout
à
fait morte est
ici de nombreux tests et qu'il faut
une odeur bnews lattes d'ascq 2
av